I want to start with as I said off
camera I spoke to you many many years
ago for children of men does it ever get
old people bringing up that movie
because it's incredible no it's amazing
it well it's a test isn't it sometimes
if you do movies and you know some
movies have a big success at the time
and a year or two later no one's talking
about it and other movies you know
children a man I think got reviewed
great didn't necessarily what didn't
make a big you know financial splash at
the time but over the time as if
anything gained in sort of you know you
know it's that probably the one film in
my career that people keep bringing up
as being you know one of their favorites
of the last however many years I think
they did an article in The New York
Times the 10-year anniversary saying how
come it's still the most relevant film
of today even though it was made 10
years ago I mean um
but he's a visionary director Alfonso
he's got on to make you know stunning
movies after that yeah I mean it's just
and I rarely use the word masterpiece
but it's a master basic I mean it's
unbelievable jumping into I get to talk
to you today this is one of these
projects that's been in gestate it's
been in development for such a long time
and it was waiting on the technology how
early on had you heard about Gemini man
he was one of those yeah it was sort of
floating around and people were talking
about it was in people's consciousness
and there were a lot of like I've
literally what I work with Andrew Niccol
who at one point was writing a version
of it I was in the elevator in the hotel
and the guy who wrote the original
script and sold it said hey I'm the guy
that first sold Gemini man as an idea so
that and that was 20 odd years ago so it
has been a film that's been you know
looking to be made for a long time and
obviously people thought there was
something very cool and interesting in
it and it got to the point where angly
said I think we're ready and we can do
it it was always they they always said
that the technology wasn't there to
achieve it properly in that so people
were nervous about making it but I think
when Aang says I think we're ready
people
move this is I've seen a few movies in
the high frame rate The Hobbit Billy
Lynn and and now this one this was the
best by a mile in terms of the high
frame
and you seen the finished version I
haven't actually no okay well but I'm
there I'm excited because they're
projecting it here in LA in exactly the
formate should be they're bringing the
projectors in to project it exactly how
it should be seen so when I see it I'll
see the full experience I will say it's
like looking through instead of a movie
screen it's like looking through a
window you know in terms of it just
being right in front of you what was it
like on set because I know the cameras
were big no yeah yelling I saw some of
Aang's previous film because he screened
me some of our ability to look at just
just show me exactly the effect of when
it's and it was incredibly visceral and
intense and actually took your brain a
little while to adjust to the
information coming at you because there
was so much detail I think in it but um
in terms of shooting it the cameras are
much bigger everything takes that bit
longer so every time you change an angle
and look a different direction
it's it's longer than it would normally
be because everything sort of takes that
long and shooting everything you shot
everything a number of versions
especially because I did most of my
stuff with the young will so you know
there was a whole number of processes
you didn't just shoot it once with will
we this once with will with a rig on
once with a body double once with
nothing in so it was a process I was
gonna say that has to be you've worked
on many different projects this has to
be like really flipping on the
imagination in terms of I guess acting
against nothing not really no because
you've got Will Smith there even if he's
got a rig on he's such a you know such a
great and and focused actor that those
scenes with him that the rig soon
disappears when you when you've got two
actors in a room just playing a scene
together whatever is going on soon sort
of disappears and you get used to it and
you know you took a you know it didn't
feel like you were it was acting like
that because ultimately it all comes
down to us to play in a scene together
what whatever is going on around us one
of the things about your character is a
know he has a good idea but I think goes
about it obviously all wrong interested
there's a lot of people have that
haha but of to talk a little bit about
reading the script for the actually want
to jump backwards reading the script for
the first time did you ever at any point
think this is gonna be like impossible
do you know what I mean to try to pull
this thing off or with Angley it's gonna
work no I thought faith in Langley
Langley thinks you know I know and I
talked to myung about it and you know
you never approach your character well I
would never approach any character with
going you know sorry I meant like with
the technology and with always with no
oh I see sorry I thought yeah my dad ya
know because he was so convinced he was
so convinced that it was ready and they
could do it and talk through the process
and was getting the best people that
were around to do it so I never felt you
know you you if you can't trust Angley
who can who can you trust ya know the
thing that I find with aim that's so
amazing is he's worked in so many
different genres and done all of them
great yeah you know he's just such a
great filmmaker you've worked with great
filmmakers what what does he like on set
and how does he compare to some of the
other people you've worked with well you
know he's very different in terms of
that he has you know he has the whole
spectrum covered you know he's doing a
film of this size and this magnitude
that he's technically so difficult and
yet he's on the phone and emailing me
about details in a line of dialogue to
say you know I'm saying is that the
right way to say this and him saying
well I think if we changed that what I
mean he's he's taking the time to do
that and at the same time has this
monster of a you know difficult movie to
be making so you know he's on top of
anything possible in terms of making
movies and loves the you know the most
state-of-the-art technology and is
interested about how we can push things
forward but he's also a true artist who
cares about details of scripts and
dialogue and nuances with it within
scenes so I think he's he's rare in that
he covers that whole spectrum you've
worked on Broadway and on the West End
I'm curious how how are they different
is are they different when you're
working on Broadway in the West End or
are they very similar good question
actually because I literally just
finished the West End a few days ago
because I don't get to meet too many
people that actually you have worked on
both right I am curious how are they
different or the same
they are different maybe the audiences
are different maybe the expectations
going in a different way I don't know I
mean it was it was unusual and sometimes
you don't know if it's the play that's
that's making you know the the
atmosphere different because I've just
done a Tennessee Williams play and the
sort of quality of the listening every
night was extraordinary on something
I've never experienced anywhere in fear
but I've got a feeling that she's
writing more than it is whether it's
Broadway or West End but um but yeah I
suppose they suppose they that they are
different I just don't know whether it's
the place or the play hopefully one day
I will see you on one of those stages
until then congratulations on this movie
thank you for giving me your time thank
you